[Music]
the corona virus pandemic is putting
healthcare systems around the world to
the test in the u.s. it's also revived a
debate over one of the most divisive
concepts and American politics should
health care be free will remove or
eliminate every obstacle necessary to
deliver our people the care that they
need in the u.s. some are worried about
whether hospitals can handle the
pandemic and what kovat 19 treatment
might cost patients while in places like
Europe Hong Kong and Australia people
are worried about hospitals too but not
so much the price tag of a hospital stay
since that's generally covered by taxes
so we wanted to know what works in a
universal health care system and what
doesn't
I guess I'm unique five different
healthcare systems today a healthcare
system doesn't exist in a silo it exists
within a culture we are gonna lead this
country into a medicare-for-all
single-payer program we have a chance of
killing Obamacare we almost in some
countries universal health care is a
point of national pride just look at the
UK when London hosted the Olympics in
2012 the opening ceremony touted the
UK's athletes and its health care system
was possible the exchange of some years
ago said the National Health Service was
the nearest thing that Great Britain had
to a religion dr. Jeffrey rivet has
documented the rise of the UK's National
Health Service I'm a doctor I'm in my
80s and I spent my entire working life
in the Health Service or in government
controlling the Health Service
zero-hour in london chamberlain speaks a
state of war exists with germany so when
for us the war broke out on 3rd
september 1939 major hospitals were
evacuated to the country temporary
hospitals were established and an
emergency hospital services was free and
organized by command and control took
over from that moment having got a
command and control system under the
threat of war there was no way of going
back as European countries dealt with
the demand for medical care that came
from World War two many built in some
form of government-run health care this
new health service will be organized on
a national scale as a public
responsibility well what was going on in
the u.s. is that President Truman put
the weight of the presidency behind a
plan to have universal health care but
he was unable to to get that through
Congress that's Martin Gorski
he's a healthcare historian and he's
thought a lot about how the American
healthcare system came to be you know
the arguments at time about American
character American national culture you
know the famous pioneer spirit the
freedom of the individual American
culture evolved over time and in the 60s
president lyndon b johnson enacted
Medicare and Medicaid today the US
government still fund some programs that
could be considered socialized medicine
think Medicare for the elderly and
disabled Medicaid for low-income
Americans and VA healthcare for veterans
America also has some of the best
doctors and research facilities in the
world but there's no universal program
that covers health care for everybody
Kelvin and Enrico drous have lived all
over the world and their family has
experienced a range of both public and
private health care systems
so I grew up in Nebraska in the middle
of the country in a small community and
so when we first met each other and then
eventually got together and got married
her coming from a country where there is
socialized benefits like socialized
health care and stuff like that
I definitely gave her a hard time for
that very very regularly up until we'd
been married for four or five years and
I still was giving her a hard time till
we moved to the UK like in most European
countries any UK resident can walk into
a hospital and get free basic care from
the NHS most prescriptions cost just $10
each kids the elderly and patients with
conditions like cancer or some cases of
diabetes don't pay anything out of
pocket if you want to pay extra for
private care because you want to get to
see a doctor faster or need more
specialized care than the NHS can
readily provide you can do that too
having that option to go private is
common in most countries with universal
health care in the States you are being
provided with a product and it's being
presented to you as it's more of like an
experience where you're going it's going
to be a really nice waiting room you're
gonna have really nice chairs in a TV on
for you whereas when we go here the
weight room is nice it's fine their
chairs that we can sit in there's you
know you're not going to be sitting in
the cold or anything like that but it is
a very different environment in both
systems there's a cost to the care the
biggest difference is whether it's being
paid for by the country as a whole or
individual patients the budget to run
the NHS in 2019 was roughly a hundred
and seventy billion dollars that money
comes mostly from taxes coming here it
was a pretty big shock you know
negotiating a salary and getting that
first paycheck and going something must
be wrong here and looking and seeing you
know 30 percent of the check was to
taxes and
all of those things but that 30% I mean
when we looked at it and broke it down
what we were paying for insurance back
in the States it wouldn't have been a
difference really I mean there's no as a
percentage of its GDP the u.s. actually
spends more on health care than any
other developed country it's roughly 17
percent in the US and just nine point
six percent in the UK researchers say
that's because of higher prices the u.s.
has higher drug prices doctor salaries
and hospital admin costs while much of
the health care sector in the u.s. is
focused on turning a profit in a country
like the UK the National Health Service
is seen as part of the government all
the main political parties are promising
more money for England's NHS but it's
needed now already delays and treatment
and staff shortages are at record levels
when the government dials back its
spending the health care system suffers
cuts to NHS providers and a 20-19 with a
roughly 700 million dollar deficit some
providers have tried to make up for that
by cutting costs and hiring private
contractors to run parts of the system
like specialised care or food services
there are definitely gone so for example
if you're getting something done that is
not emergent it does take time to get in
and get seen as hospital services get
cut and the population gets older UK
hospitals have become overcrowded
causing sometimes months long wait times
for non-emergency procedures
even if America were to create its own
universal health care system one day it
would look much different than anything
that exists elsewhere today the u.s.
already has a trillion dollar health
insurance industry there's hundreds of
millions of dollars spent on health care
lobbying every year and the cultural
attitude towards taxes is just different
from other countries so politicians in
the US have proposed a range of
changes from replacing the Affordable
Care Act altogether to a single-payer
system or a mix of private and public
options I think that it's easy for
people in in smaller countries like the
UK just say well why don't they just do
something like this in the States and I
think it's really easy for someone in
the states to say well you're a really
small country of course you can do it
and I think both people are right
the corona virus pandemic has brought
the government's attention to the health
care system Congress passed a bill
making all Kove 819 testing free for
patients the White House plans to pay
hospitals for coronavirus treatment for
people without insurance and states have
been pouring resources into providing
care for people during the crisis still
recent polls conducted before the
pandemic showed many Americans just
aren't sold on the idea of a fully
government-run and health care system
but coronavirus is likely to weigh heavy
on the lines of American voters as they
decide who will lead the country forward
and what they want their health care
system to look like
[Music]